I'm extremely pleased to Alan Eustace is
the keynote speaker today he is the
perfect representative of this leg of
the tripod is he'll put it because he's
been a real visionary at Google directly
related to this technology and a
tremendous supporter of Carnegie Mellon
in every way Carnegie Mellon enjoys an
excellent relationship with Google that
gets deeper and broader it seems with
every passing day Google opened an
engineering center on our campus five
years ago and it's grown from a handful
of people to now closing in on 200
people and we expected to continue to
grow even beyond that the building that
they went into we opened about seven
years ago and it's a building that they
shared with Intel and apple and Disney
all companies that created pittsburgh
engineering or indoor research centers
which is why we designed the building in
the first place it was probably the only
building in the world that had those
four companies in it simultaneously
Google got so big though that they've
outgrown the space and now we're in a
part of pittsburgh development called
bakery square in a part of pittsburgh
called East Liberty not far from here
we're sorry to see them leave campus but
they're not far away and we're doing
everybody can to maintain connectivity
it's a great success story for the
university but also for Pittsburgh and
great emblem for how pittsburgh has
recreated and redefined itself from the
steelmaking capital of the world to now
a thriving center with a very diverse
economy and great strength in the
technology sectors Allen and Google were
very much behind the global connection
project a project that was designed to
enable people to meet and interact with
others across the globe and of course
gigapan came out of that project I want
to thank Google
and Alan we're not only able to develop
a new tool but also to put in the hands
of people literally all over the world
of course including you we believe here
at Carnegie Mellon there's this
tremendous potential for new uses of the
technology and new decked out new
technologies that will come out of it
which of course is exactly why you've
all come together for this conference
and I wish you best of luck in that
effort Alan Eustace received his
bachelor's master's and PhD degrees all
from the University of Central Florida
prior to joining Google in 2002 he was
for 15 years at the Western Research
Laboratory which I guess started life as
a deck laboratory than a compact
laboratory and then became a
hewlett-packard lambdoid he was with it
during all that time working on chip
design and rose to being director of the
Western Research Laboratory in 1999 at
Google not only is he a senior VP when
focus on technology but also heads up
many of Google's community related
activities including the meat aboard
scholarship fund for which are also very
grateful it's a great leadership just
another example of Alan's tremendous
vision and leadership and with our great
gratitude i'm pleased to present to you
Alan Eustace so very kind of you
so I like this place already because i
arrived at nine o'clock and it was empty
and that's just like home then we have
kind of a seven minute rule at Google
you know you you can be seven minutes
late for any meeting and that's falling
so it's fantastic to be here you know
somebody asked me the other day about
investing or in the early stages of
gigapan and and you know they asked well
you know the technology was kind of knew
them there wasn't that much to show for
it and I I told them I said well you
don't really invest in technology you
invest in people and you invest in
visions and then the technology happens
and I think what I love about this
project in La in general is it's not
just about the technology you know
technology is kind of a dime a dozen
sometimes but it's what you do with the
technology it's how technology impacts
people it's how it spreads you know how
it how it changes people's lives how it
changes the way people work and learn
and things like that that was that was
the hook you know technology was was a
part of it and an important part of it
but I think that that dream in that
vision and how it interacts with what we
do at Google was really really important
you know we live in a very interesting
time right now I mean I you have to kind
of pinch yourself every once in a while
about the changes that have happened in
you know the last 25 or 30 years the
technology right now has I mean it's
just incredible i mean cpu is you think
cpus of you know central processing
units and computers have gotten a lot
faster and they have you know you know
roughly 3,000 times faster or something
like that which sounds a lot i mean
three thousand times faster is great but
that's pales in comparison to other
mediums and especially disk computer
disk in the same period of time that the
central processing element of a computer
got three thousand times faster disk
have gotten four million times cheaper
per byte which is incredible
I mean it's just amazing 4 million times
better in 25 or 30 years and that's that
that's that's amazing networks have
gotten incredibly faster I mean there
was no such thing as a network you know
I remember the first network when I went
to school it was uunet you know an
ARPANET and innocent you know in SF had
a small network and things and and
communication you actually had to choose
your route on a mail message so if I
want to send a mail message to some
other computer I had to tell it where to
go like let's start at my university UCF
I want you to go to you know you see vax
you know and then i watch that message
to go to this other computer and i
wanted to go to another computer and
then I want it to get and you'd have to
figure out the route of all your
messages and that was just a relatively
short time ago and now you know
international communication is pretty
much everywhere there's also a
commercial revolution that's taking
place which is buyers and sellers
anywhere it can become connected and and
that's really one of the focuses of
Google is the whole idea that anybody
can actually connect with anybody else
in the world right now and to give you
an example if I was trying to start say
a worldwide advertising campaign you
know five years ago or ten years ago how
would I do it well I'd worked with lots
of different newspapers and press and
I'd work it with magazines and all this
kind of stuff and I would try to build
this campaign a worldwide it would take
a long time to take a huge number of you
know different agencies and stuff like
that probably take two or three years to
execute and all of a sudden you know I
would do all of this and all the student
for the first time i'd have this
campaign if i was a company that wanted
to reach an audience outside of the
united states you know it would take
years to do you know i mean ford motor
company if they want to expand into
europe how you know how how much effort
how much capital would that take but in
this world that we live in right now
individuals can reach other individuals
instant you put up a web page anybody
can see it Google will index it probably
actually quite fast
and put it out in front of lots of
different people if i'ma if I'm if I'm
trying to sell something I sell to
anybody in the world I mean the growth
of Google crossed international borders
accidentally I don't know whether
anybody understood that that the way the
Internet is basically structured there
are no geographic boundaries in it so if
you have a crawl which is how you
actually go out in the web and find
information it automatically goes across
geographic boundaries it automatically
goes across languages matter of fact
across languages search kind of just
worked you know it worked in all these
different languages immediately our
search page was so simple that that we
actually got volunteers to translate it
into other languages so we actually
volunteers translated a hundred and
Google into 140 languages for us just
for fun so that's how we got into a
bunch of different places and I think
that's the context in which we live
right now is this whole information
sharing connection has now become you
know so so ingrained in the fabric we
don't even think about it anymore
there's also a sociological revolution
going on that I kind of call the
democratization of information that it
used to be that information was a
closely guarded secret of a few I mean
the whole thing information is power
right I mean you remember that
information is power and so you would
hold tight to all information you would
glance at it every once in a while you
would make some decisions and you were
smarter than everybody else on the
planet because you had the information
and a dinner and then now it's
completely different it's it's inverted
you know information is something you
share the information that you use to
make decisions is no longer the
information that you've carefully
collected and guarded you know 99
percent of all your decision-making is
based on information somebody else has
graciously shared with you and that's
just a totally different outlook and
that's I think what's changed in the
world wide web is a sociological change
as much it was a technological
gical change information is kind of the
lifeblood now of what we do no one would
buy a car without looking on the web and
no one would buy anything without
looking on the web you don't no one
would introduce themselves i mean people
go on dates nowadays they look up
somebody right you know it's like it's a
given that we're going to find out about
something before we jump into it our
decision-making you know people people
talk about the you know what has the
world wide web done for us I mean what's
it changed in our life and you know why
is it generating value and obviously
it's generating value for companies you
know like our company and other
companies but what it's really changed
is the quality of decision making you
know the decisions that you make are
some percentage better okay I don't care
pick a number ten percent better the
fact that I can look up information on
the web before I make a decision makes
my decision making better what's that
worth into the gross not you know global
domestic product of better
decision-making across the entire globe
and there you start to see the value
that's being generated on the web the
googles mission is pretty simple it's to
organize the world's information and
make it universally accessible and
useful we break that apart organized so
it's not if you have without
organization you just have data you know
data isn't actually very valuable you
know you can store it on disk and stuff
but once you organize it you get
information but that's not enough you
have to make information accessible and
then you have to make it useful on a
global scale and you'll see how that
fits together with GigaPan and not in
just a few minutes now I had this I I
was somebody who looked at Moore's law
which is the how fast computers are
getting and how dense computers are
getting you know Gordon Moore worked at
Intel and you know he's famous for this
law about why things are getting
substantially cheaper and faster and
more powerful in technology over time
and I looked at that in I I had in my
mind I had I had
pure vision of where the world was going
to go and it went like this Randy
sitting there he probably had the same
vision but he won't admit it may be you
know I thought everything was getting so
much cheaper so much faster that
eventually everything we currently store
in data centers would be shrunk down and
all be on my cell phone you know that I
would never need all these data centers
and instead in that same period of time
everything has shrunk down and I do have
a cell phone but at the same time Google
and other companies are building
enormous data centers probably the
largest data centers that have ever been
built on our planet with more compute
power more networking all this kind of
stuff so what happened you know what
there was a point where everything was
shrinking you know Dave people were
worried about their data centers
basically shrinking away and the data
centers going to be filled but nothing
but space and it didn't happen it went
the opposite way so so there's a couple
reasons for that when is this explosion
of data that that that I didn't realize
at the time that that Moore's law would
not only make the things that we the
computers and the storage and stuff a
lot better but it will allow people to
generate much more complex data and that
data has to go somewhere so in the
imagery case it's very obvious that you
can now build images there is 0 a size
and complexity that has never ever been
considered with the level of detail
that's never been concerned considered
and that's just an images video HD video
you know five years ago there wasn't
even a TV that would actually do HD
video and it was millions of dollars
worth of equipment to basically generate
imagery though and that good and during
this time now that's accessible to all
of us through the efforts of it ilya and
gigapan and you know now these
incredibly dense and rich images are
available to everybody and I think
that's what where I went wrong I never
realized that the explosion of that what
was making it easier to store data would
make it easier
to create data the second place I was
wrong was the computational power that's
necessary to look at and use that data I
there's lots of different examples of
this but but but search is it at least a
good example when you do a search on
Google you type in a few characters
there what happens behind the scenes and
what happens is is actually kind of
straightforward philosophically you know
in the end of a book you have an index
ok and in an index you've got a word you
know let's say heart and then condition
so next to heart that that occurs on
pages 12 and 17 and 12 and condition
occurs on 12 35 and 40 and that index
allows you to go through and find out
where heart and condition happened the
same time and when you do that through
all the billions of web pages and rank
them you'll find all the pages in the
entire world that have that in it and
that's how the search engine works but
the interesting part about it is when
you type a search thousands of machines
are working on your behalf
simultaneously my phone to do that I
mean if I shrunken all the data down to
this which probably don't what happened
now but it'll probably happen in the
next five years but the computational
power would still take you know I don't
know maybe three months to get that
solution there and that's not quite fast
enough we found that latency is an
important thing and so so it's it's
interesting the way that the world has
changed you need computational power the
that's really the basis for what we're
calling the cloud now which is the
transformation of things that are on
your device to a place where you can
actually access them from any possible
place I mean right now we've got to the
point where you put a piece of
information there and you can access it
access that information from the phone
from a desktop computer now with google
TV you can do it on a TV
you know you can do it from anywhere on
the globe the amount of information that
you can access is so much larger than
it's ever been before the amount of
information right now in the last ten
years that is accessible as exploding
and I you know when I started Google
which is probably about nine years ago
it was the web when you went to a search
engine you type something it was the web
was all you got and web was big and it's
obviously big you know at the time it
was a couple billion in a couple billion
things but still it was just a couple
billion and now in the last nine years
behind the back behind the curtains you
know you now have the web you have
images you have videos you have news you
have email you have scholarly content so
all the scholarly content is migrating
on there so all that's accessible to you
now you know there's magazines there's
you know streets street view books you
know if we're going to organize all the
world's information we can't leave out
something important like books you know
books are kind of the thing that all
information has over the over eternity I
mean it's the storehouse of the world's
knowledge and has been for years and so
one of the implications of our mission
is to scan all the world's books and to
try to put them in a in a place where
you can actually access them let me just
talk about one element and that's the
whole maps and satellite because i think
it's it's it it kind of puts the thing
in perspective nine years ago the web
was not geo-located in any way so we had
two billion pages but they they weren't
anywhere right they weren't located as
on a point in space and you know as a
result they were less valuable and we
bought a little company called keyhole
and another small company that did maps
and that brought us to really
interesting elements when is it brought
us maps that were explorable it was a
met before a map was just a map and that
but the idea that you could dive into a
map and you could slide it right
left was new you know Bria knew no one
had ever done slidable maps that you
could move around and and so that was a
that was it was a start but then we
bought keyhole and we got satellite
imagery for the whole globe you know now
the satellite imagery it's something
that you could do at you know I mean if
you were in a government maybe you had
access to satellite imagery but nobody
else did and now when you take maps and
you overlay satellite imagery and then
you take all the web pages in the world
and you put them you know like push pins
on to the math now you have information
that you've never seen before and now
people can take that information and put
create mashups place their information
on those maps just as well and then you
would from there you have to ask well
what other things do you need to know
and that's what caused street view so
Street View said you know I'd really
like to know the information that is in
you know the when i drive down the
street I get a totally different picture
of what something is then if I just look
at it from the map or satellite and so
Street View was an attempt to say that's
really valuable information let's take
all of that and let's overlay it and so
now I have web and I have maps and I
have all these things all over late so
now there's piece of information that I
would never be able to get in any other
way and that information is now
tremendously more valuable than it ever
was before and it's led to other things
like you know what do you do input cases
where there are no max you know if there
are no maps in the world you know in
many parts of the world how do you
create them well it turns out that the
same method that it was used by of
user-generated content in other places
can apply to maps so what we did was we
created this thing called map maker and
Matt maker basically somebody lays out
the satellite imagery which we give them
and they start drawing roads you know
they start drawing roads they start
laying in parts they start naming things
and things like that and so for all
these places we launched this tool which
is really fun and interesting tool and
then we have this creep they have this
great picture where they take the you
know the earth
imagery and they start populating with
the maps that get submitted by everybody
else in the world and all of a sudden
little areas that were dark in the world
now light up with a map you know and
qingyang the maps they're being used in
Haiti for the relief efforts were almost
all generated by people and map maker
and then they were used in a disaster
situation you know but but the maps were
created by people people are the ones
that are creating the interesting
content right now and I think that's a
huge change youtube you know the story
of you know we acquired youtube but the
backstory of youtube was that we had a
product called Google video I was almost
identical to YouTube in every way shape
or form you know it would play videos
you know you click on it the video would
play all that stuff was fine but YouTube
was going like this and Google video was
going like this why you know when we're
scratching our heads why is this big
difference and by the time we had
figured it out it was too late and the
difference was user-generated content
they made it easy to upload videos we
were indexing videos and doing a
fantastic job of it they were enabling
people to create videos the fundamental
difference and we were so far behind at
that point we had to buy a company which
was very expensive to basically catch up
because we missed a huge and important
transition in the world which is
user-generated content was going to be
more important than just indexing and I
think that that that changed our whole
mindset of the company and I think it's
been really really important you know
one thing that we didn't miss thankfully
was mobile and the importance of mobile
and if you look back five years ago a
mobile phone was a mobile phone it was a
phone that's all it did and it's kind of
amazing to think about the transition
that's happened in phones
magically behind our back that we don't
even think about I mean a phone now has
is becoming you're the most marvelous
thing that we've ever seen because
before you could talk to it and you can
listen to it communicate but now this
phone can see it's got a camera you know
it can hear you know you can talk to
it's got a microphone you can it can it
can listen you know it can communicate
it can take pictures it knows where it
is it's got a GPS in it it can find
itself on the earth you know by itself
something that I can't do sometimes
without it it knows which direction it's
pointing it's got a compass inside of it
you know so you can do things like the
sky map which is actually a really nice
collaboration actually between CMU and
which is it wasn't on your list which is
you can load the star map of the world
and you can you can look like this and
as you rotate the stars change behind
you you know and you can tell what
galaxies are out there and things like
that just by going across if there's
some interesting thing you can poke at
and you can learn more about it but it's
all because of the technology here it
knows if it's moving it's got
accelerometers in it so it'll get it
knows when it's moving so this device
now has become an input device for
learning lots about things it's also the
focus for a big technology shift that I
think the cloud has given us the ability
to do which is take information here
send it up to a cloud and do something
with it and there's a couple great
examples that are coming right now I
don't know that you guys have been
playing with with phones lately and
applications lately but but one of the
things that that this thing can do is
voice recognition now you guys know this
I mean I I personally at world and other
places have been investing in speech
recognition pretty much for 25 years and
five years ago seven years ago I was
convinced
it was a technology it would never
happen I mean worship I mean we are we
all were investing it but it just we
never thought it would happen because it
was just too hard of a problem but
what's changed is if you can take speech
and you can have it work with a thousand
computers simultaneously doing it and if
you can train it this was the thing I
was always missing was the combination
of doing of doing the computation and
then if you didn't know the right answer
present a few answers and allow somebody
to pick the right one and then all the
machine learning algorithms have a
feedback loop and all of a sudden you
know magical things happen and and in
our case when we launched a language a
speech you know you know a new language
which we're doing I think we'll probably
be up to 20 languages by the end of this
year when we launched one it starts out
not that good but then what happens is
you tell it you know you do an SMS and
you send it to somebody and and it goes
thing through and says you know here's
what it think you said and then you can
correct it and lo and behold those
Corrections go back to us or if you say
I want to find you know CMU and it says
some other thing but there's a list
there and you point to it and you point
in it says CMU it will now know that
what you really uh turd with CMU and so
now you can learn in ways that we have
never been able to to do before and the
same thing with translation translation
was also something I never thought would
actually happen because the rules for
languages were way too complicated and
then we threw that out you know the
world has thrown out you know a
rule-based translation for the most part
right now and it's all statistical show
me enough data in one language and show
me enough translations of exactly that
and I'll make up a mathematical model
that actually relates the two more data
better translation and so right now we
have translations probably in 40
languages you know and it's just amazing
what you can do this phone right now i
mean i could probably demo it here but
you know i can say you know find me a
taxi and translate into one of 40
different languages and well the speech
part doesn't actually work with 40
languages we call it 20 lang
just and it will be able to translate
that and I can hold it up to the cab
driver and I can tell it to take me to
the airport in any of those language so
that's what's changed data computation
phones are changing the world and
they're changing it really really fast
but that's not the big point that I was
trying to make here that the thing
that's interesting about the world that
we're creating in all of this is the
ability for individual people to post
things get that back and learn from the
environment in a way that we've never
had any chance of doing before and I
think that's going to change what we
think of about a search engine you know
right now in some sense a search engine
is something that you use to find
something so if you know you type if
you're interested in some topic you type
the topic in and we find all the people
that have said something about that
particular topic and we're very happy
with the way that works but but there's
something else that you need is we need
to become a search engine that is
capable that you come to as a place to
discover something not just to find
something and there's a big difference
between discovery and finding there was
an article that was written recently
about our search engines making us dumb
and there's a there's a you know III was
a you know I mean I couldn't believe
anybody would say that because I always
thought they were making us a lot
smarter because there was a lot more
information there but there was an
element of truth there that surgeons are
really good about finding something if
somebody else has already done the work
for you you know but it doesn't help you
actually do the work yourself in some
sense it it's not it's a great way for
learning but discovery is something
that's quite different and in discovery
is a key element of humans I mean we've
advanced because of discovery
not because of anything else we have in
advance because somebody else has done a
paper and we read it it's because
somebody actually went to the to the
trouble of learning something was very
new and i think one when the interesting
things about discovery is how it's often
obvious in hindsight you know that once
you've actually got a solution you read
about now say oh that was obvious and i
think it's one of the reasons why you
know sometimes I you know great
discoverers have not been appreciated in
their own time because everything looks
obvious I mean Copernicus you know that
I mean how could anybody believe that
you know everything revolved around the
earth you know was just so complicated
and in hindsight it seems simple but
even in the time it wasn't said it
wasn't considered simple and and I feel
like right now we are actually in a very
interesting time because we as
scientists and and as technologists I
think I've gotten to the point where
we've made technology inaccessible in a
certain strange way where we depend on
other people sometimes to solve a
problem for us that we could solve
ourselves and an example of this my dad
and I used to laugh at at you know like
lots of different things that we would
see but one of the ones I remember
pretty vividly was was a Dear Abby
column and there was Dear Abby as this
for people that are young they might not
even know it I think dear abby still
around but you know people write letters
asking you know questions and Dear Abby
would consult experts and those experts
would tell the answer and one of the
Dear Abby columns that my dad who is a
mechanical engineer and and you know
very you know love to solve problems
just in general but this Dear Abby thing
was a was a letter that says does a
shower use less water than then a tub
and it was you know I mean so she
consulted multiple experts and there was
a little differences of opinion on
whether showers use more water than tubs
and my dad and I just laughed
hysterically for hours about this
because there's a simple way to test
this
you get in the tub with a shower you
plug up to the bottom of the tub and you
take a shower and then you ask yourself
at the end of that shower is there
enough water in the bath to have a bath
or not but somehow we have lost this
sins that people can solve problems and
and I feel like that's what's missing
you know a lot of the science and
technology stuff that we're doing right
now why aren't people interested in
science anymore well somehow this whole
thing of discovery you know is lost you
know the idea that i can solve problems
and i think we as technologists make
this problem worse because we make
technology and accessible and we do it
all the time we create all this jargon
associated with our disciplines that
makes it seem like wow you're really
smart when a lot of times we're not
being smart we're confusing things we're
making ourselves seem smarter I'm from
computer architecture so there's lots of
examples in computer architecture I
spent like so there's there's whole
graduate courses where pieces of them
talk about pipelining it's it's a
fundamental thing there's pipelining and
super pipelining and all this stuff and
pipelining is the way CPU is basically
processed data in a very interesting way
so that you can overlap computation and
and there's lots of stuff there but when
you get to the bottom of all of that
it's a washer and a dryer that's all it
is you know put stuff in a washer you
move it over the dryer you put more
stuff in a washer you know when the
dryer is done you take it out there you
move it that's all I did but but but
they didn't say that in my graduate
computer architecture class you know it
took a while for you to figure out that
the thing that that's really what's
happening here and and you know I feel
like I feel like we're the ones that are
responsible so so so what we need to do
to change the philosophy is to start
making data more accessible to people
start making ways to explore more
accessible and I think that really the
catch for me on GigaPan
I won't tell you this you know now now
five years later or whatever but there
was there's when you sum it up gigapan
is about explorable imagery with tagging
so those three things right and all of
them are fantastic the imagery section
images are more powerful than any other
mechanism of communicating information
they've always been the most powerful I
mean our eyes are just marbles you know
in human biology I mean there's such
marvels that the you know intelligent
design people think there's no way that
you know Darwin could ever created
something as marvelous as the human eye
and but it's it's interesting at just
how powerful those things are an image
is not just worth a thousand words and
it's worth it's worth way more than that
and so the imagery stuff was very
interesting to me and especially imagery
at scale everything at Google is about
at scale so no matter what you do is it
at scale can you scale this is it going
to work I know this will work in a
really small domain but will it work
broadly you know is it applicable to
lots of different disciplines that's
what scaling is all about so when you
talked about imagery it was imagery at
scale it was democratization of image
and scale but the second hook was
explored explorable because exploration
is a really important thing and I feel
like it's something that's missing from
the ethos right now the idea that an
image you can actually dive down in it
and go deep enough to learn something
and nobody else knows you know that's
the important thing and then the idea of
tagging that you can add a piece of
information to a image on something that
you found that nobody else knows and you
can share it with everybody those three
components were the thing that grabbed
us because our mission is to organize
the world's information and if it's
important and critical source of
information
is is images we have to be involved so
it was kind of a given that we would
find it I know you have worked really
hard selling it but given how tightly
that that fit with our mission it was
obvious but i think the real beauty five
years from now 10 years from now 20
years from now about the work that's
going on is the idea that anybody can
look at that information that anybody
can learn something that anybody can
contribute that that that imagery is a
is a is a is a playpen it's a it's a
starting point not an ending point and
that it will change the perceptions that
people have about many different areas
so I want to thank you for inviting now
and thank you for allowing me the
opportunity I always get jazzed and
excited and energized every time that I
talked with ela I feel like what he's
trying to do here is an important step
not just for people not just for
children I have a five-year-old in 10
year old you know getting them excited
about what the next generation of
technology can do for them is very
exciting to me but but I think it's
important and I can't say that about
that many things that they're important
and so I want thank you for all the work
that you're doing and the continuation
of that work so that you said you wanted
to do question service I'd love to have
some interaction with the audience thank
you for the fantastic lecture
well I'm not the expert on it but but
they don't train they don't change for
particular voices you know which to me
is astounding that they don't because
the fact that it works across you know
the problem with the systems that you
have to training your voice is they
start out really inaccurate and they get
more and more accurate over time and so
I never thought that you would actually
have a voice independent speech system
that would actually work I do think that
tailoring two voices over time they'll
actually be important and and since
these are individual devices not shared
devices that we could do a really good
job of that I also think that that it's
important to build language models for
you know now they're not just working
about language they're working about
dialects inside of languages so if you
can recognize particular dialects inside
of languages you can also often map them
in a speaker independent fashion but
still with a dependent you know mapping
to a particular language model so that's
the direction where we're trying to go
but I think you're right that the next
generation will actually will actually
be much more personalized matter of fact
just in general the future will be
personalized across all information I
feel like even search engines the future
of that will involve personalization
when you search for something if you're
a cardiologist searching for something
on the heart what you want to get is
very different than what my grandmother
wants to get on heart so the idea of
personalization won't just apply to
speech it will apply to everything
seems like Google's up by March last few
years really hi uh Sam stall taking slow
ya know I like Microsoft I actually know
a lot of people at Microsoft's are never
say anything about Microsoft they're
great company the you know I think that
the the major thing that we try to do is
is try to stay fast moving I think
that's the most important thing that you
can do as a company in anything that
your company does too slow people down
you have to fight pretty hard against
but as companies get big there are more
they're more opinions and reaching
consensus takes a while I think the best
thing you can do to avert that is just
be incredibly transparent and then have
clear lines of authority and decision
making but you have to be really careful
because all great ideas come from the
bottom of the company I have not come up
with I've been there nine years I don't
think I've come up with a single good
idea but what has happened was I can
support some good ideas and so the
important thing is to try to try to make
sure that you maintain a bottoms-up
culture and try to get good ideas you
know funded and and try not to slow
people down you know the worst thing you
can do is actually slow people down and
you know so that's what we concentrate
on try to keep our groups small
fast-moving you know getting rid of
barriers you know clear decision making
but to try to just you know I don't know
support innovation that's the biggest
thing
the reticle responsibilities in terms of
displaying entities well we obviously
took a huge and controversial Stand to
take our search engine out of China and
move it to to Hong Kong because we we
felt we can no longer participate in
censorship that was required to have you
know computers in China it was a very
difficult decision on lots of different
dimensions for us as a company because
we do believe in participation in in in
information our goal is to provide
information for people and when we went
in there it was one of the toughest
decisions we made as a company because
we knew that by going in there and
putting our servers there we were going
to have to censor some amount of
information but we figured that the
ninety-nine percent that we weren't
censoring was more important than the
one percent that we were but that became
more difficult out of the time and we
reversed ourselves on that decision and
decided that we couldn't do that anymore
that as an information being in the
information business had certain
requirements for us and that it wasn't
that we have any problem with sensory I
mean I you know I'm not making a
philosophical statement about whether
censoring is good bad or indifferent but
when you ask us to do it and we have to
do it you know for us i think that
crossed a line for us and we made it we
made a decision you know to pull out
which which you know is very
controversial even today because we're
you know some would say we're abandoning
you know the world's largest and fastest
growing market we're not we still have
great market share I mean you can still
get the beauty of the Internet is it
still crosses divides
you can still get our search and we're
actually a very popular search engine
inside of China and but it's a
complicated problem it really is i think
you know one aspect of it is the people
in China were huge supporters of us
going into China and censoring you know
they don't think it's as big a deal as
we think it's a big deal so it's not
simple oh I mean that's what I've
learned as an executive well maybe it's
just because of my job but but by the
time a problem gets to me it's a hard
problem you know it's really hard you
know the black-and-whites got dead with
lots of other people and and now
everything's great
wrong
just hearing that
yeah I know I it's a it's a great
question privacy it that that's one of
the things that bubbles up to me all the
time or our little all the time because
it's so important you know for me I the
privacy things are it's really important
and one of the valley one of the
beauties of having an international
organization like we have 40 engineering
sites all over the world is that I get
to hear that the opinions in Europe
which are actually much stronger and
privacy and always have been on data
protection in here so I actually get the
perspectives globally on privacy rather
than just here because I think sometimes
the voices are stronger in other places
you know the first there's various
principles that you know I personally
apply to this if we're taking some
information from you say a search
history or something it's got to be we
got to make it valuable to you we can't
take information that's too into us and
not provide value back for you and
especially if we take something for you
don't provide any of any value to you
and provide lots of value to third
parties so one of the things that a lot
of search engines used to do is
basically sell search histories to other
people and all this thing we don't do
that you know if you give it to us we're
trying to provide the value to you and
so that so so the first thing is make it
useful and the analogy I'd use as credit
cards I mean weevil may have lots of
information about your searches but
credit card companies know everything
about your life they do you know my
credit card basically tells where I been
tells who I've associated with it what
presents I bought you know if I had
affairs I'm sure would have hotels which
I don't by the way I just want to make
give her the record but but everything
about you is they say on the credit card
so why do you do that and it's because
you get something really valuable so to
say it the first part does provide
usefulness to that and protect that
information as if it was your own the
second the second piece is be
transparent you know so try have ways so
people can find out what information I
have about you
okay and that's really important and so
we have tools that you can find out well
we have we keep your search history here
it is do you want it do you want us to
keep it or not if you don't want us to
keep it eliminated if you want to take
out these three searches do that you
know if you use our chrome go into
incognito mode figure out a way
basically so you can do everything in
that we're going to basically forget you
know so give transparency and options to
people and real choices about how we use
that information and I think think those
things are important but but it's also
important for us to use that to help you
you know a search history is very
valuable because it gives us a context I
mean without a history every query is by
itself alone you know you're giving us
three words you know or two words or
something like that and expecting us to
guess whether you're a neurosurgeon or
whether you're you know a you know
schoolteacher or whether you're history
professor or whatever and with just a
little more context we can do a much
better job for you and so so so for us
that that's real important but those are
the tenants of privacy from all but
should we have to end this so first of
all this
you